[Music]
District Council today we're down at
good streets in rangiora and we're
celebrating the official relaunch we've
put a lot of time redeveloping this
laneway and it's turned into an amazing
Community Asset
when redesigning good Street you want it
to be a place where people would spend
time so we've got some lovely seating
areas we've got a stage for performers
some beautiful nighttime lightings and I
know people are really fond of the
bright red lamp posts as well we've got
musicians down here today we've got
other activations and all the retailers
are really excited to welcome you so
come on down check it out it's in the
heart of Londa and come and support your
local town
coming here today and being part of this
here and hearing the excitement that
there's been in our community about good
street it's really great
we hope that this work that we've put
into here will add to your businesses
and to our communities experience as you
come along and enjoy this particular
area but we're looking forward to this
Lane becoming a real Community Asset and
one that will make a a fantastic venue
for concerts and events in the future
and today is the first of that where
we've got the curio club and also all
manner of other entertainers here so
thank you everyone again for being here
it's my pleasure to declare that this
area the re-launch of this area are
officially open thank you everyone
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]